[Music]
[Music]
okay bye all right bye bye
okay one more big one don't go i don't
don't
know
dwight told me about it earlier
dwight
promised dwight couldn't get it up for
nelly no no no no it's not me i'm going
to prove it right here and now
what are you doing
stop that wait
stop that stop it
fine it was me i couldn't i had a
problem with aaron last night happy
i had a lot on my mind last night
and i didn't perform
okay happens to plenty of guys
it's usually not followed by a giant
workplace discussion and an interview
every guy in this room has been touched
by this
affliction tuna d-dog
um
um
i i have
other issues
i'm terrible at math
overweight
you
you're in great shape a lot better shape
than i am tell you what
it seems
andy is the only one with this problem
fascinating fascinating i don't really
see what the problem is aaron doesn't
even like sex remember you said it feels
like getting tackled by skeleton
empty mine too
oh boy okay
[Music]
okay then
so
where were we
bowling
yep yep yep
you didn't eat much there jimbo
oh
initially i did
want some meat oh sure little piece
ooh no mushroom though
i forgot yeah thank you
i have recently taken a lover well
that's great congratulations
who's the lucky lady pam's mom
what pam's mom helene remember from your
wedding
you're messing with me
about what you did not have sex with
pam's mom oh big time what kind of cars
to drive she drives a green camera and
the seats go all the way down
all the way down oh my god
oh my god
what what if pam was a lesbian
what if she brought her partner in to
work would that be crossing the line no
what if they made out in front of
everybody well that would be at home and
i told everybody everything about it
okay i'm lost okay well then let's act
it out pam you will be girl a and girl b
will be
okay use the doll
pam
you know what
i love phyllis
you know what else
i think she is gorgeous
i think she is an incredibly
incredibly attractive person
come here come here chris come home go
come on you don't have to worry i'm not
good i'm not reporting i'm not worried
hr you know what the only thing i am
worried about is getting a boner
michael
5k means 5 kilometers not 5 000 miles
hey hey oh my god what are you doing you
said come in no i didn't just oh my god
please
so i closed the door but the image of
his
dangling participle still burned in my
eyes i can imagine
come in
may i enter the room yes or come in
see how i did that
that's the way you should enter a room
you knock and then you wait for the all
clear you couldn't have taken off all
your clothes in the men's room yes but i
have an office so why would i do that on
average how many hours a day do you
spend naked in your office just ballpark
european offices are naked all the time
they're so not
uh oh
she's doing it again
phyllis has gotten into audiobooks and
lately she's been listening to fifty
shades of grey which
if you don't know what it is it's a book
about a um
it's porn yeah
seriously
okay this is unacceptable it's
officially a hostile work environment
somebody just needs to get our attention
until it's not okay to do this in public
be careful i pulled my mom's dog off a
pillow once and i got bit just ignore
sooner or later she'll finish oh i heard
it ah good oh what
phyllis is masturbating
in the office right now as we speak can
we skip the color commentary and just
have andy go out there and fire her
he can't do that turns out just she's
allowed to have feelings of sexual
arousal doesn't become a violation until
she physically acts on it
why is phyllis so aroused she's
listening to fifty shades of grey
well there you go that's muy caliente
okay you are useless i'll take care of
this
what the hell it's okay guys she's no
longer horny excuse me dirty birdie
what
gonna have this back at the end of the
day
i'm still having a bit of trouble
understanding the importance of loyalty
so let's let's use an example take aaron
aaron's boyfriend andy is away across
the ocean yeah so is it all right for
her to flirt with
creed for example let's try it out
no let's let's not say greed let's say
mr x well i think it would be immoral
for aaron to cheat on andy oh i'm sorry
didn't you cheat on andy yes and he
didn't like it does mr x know that aaron
has a boyfriend or did aaron keep that
from mr x okay this is really hard to
follow can we just say pete cause that's
the guy that aaron's flirting with
well andy's cute but he's too vanilla
whereas pete he's just one sick dude i
mean you know this guy likes to get
weird i'm just gonna say this one more
time pete and i haven't done anything
it's true yeah right with slamming bods
like that they ain't playing checkers oh
hey guys
i want to do something nice for you
because you
did something so nice for me earlier i
want you to go in there i want you to
buy one item on me as a thank you
come on
get in here let's face it most guys are
from the dark ages they're cavemen and
they like a woman to be showing
her cleavage and to be wearing eight
inch heels
and to be wearing
um see-through
underpants
but for me
a woman looks best when she is
just absolutely naked
[Music]
you don't want anything
my treat
some panties or
a thong or a g-string
t-back
get a nice bra
padded bra
see-through push-up lace
thigh-high bustier anythi it just you
know what i would love
to buy you a fresh set of underwear
what are you doing in here this is the
woman's room you're in here i pay for
that privilege
okay i'm a pretty normal guy i do one
weird thing
i like to go in the women's room for
number two i've been caught several
times and i have paid dearly
you